The solutions here are 3 plus or minus root 10, all divided by 2. Great work,
using that square root method, if you got this one correct. We start solving
this equation by adding 10 to both sides. This leaves us with the square
isolated on the left and positive 10 on the right. Now that we have something
squared alone, we can take the square root of both sides. This means we will
have 2x minus 3 on the left. And plus or minus root 10 on the right. We add 3
to both sides to get 2x by itself and then divide both sides by positive 2.
This leaves us with 1 x in our answer. And again if you really wanted to, you
could split this up into two separate fractions, 3 halves plus or minus root 10
divided by 2. Either form is the same.